I'm in the her softball league you're
gonna have people from numerous
backgrounds that did and I could tip it
up catch that fit up there and raw
people that fit up in this old goat but
they went to prison they went to jail
but when we started this league they
came together the purpose of this league
was to bring all the Crips together and
be a family well if it wasn't a softball
league I would never met tree fighting
within the Crips is common and can often
be very deadly in 2016
the group of neighborhoods in Los
Angeles got together to form a softball
league as a way to heal the community
I've been through a whole decent a lot
I've been shot at six times I've been
around the dope Dillon
I don't been around the territory
battles and when I hit the streets and I
learnt the street way of doing things
and I had to just sit up there nothing
to ride the roller coaster I meant
Terrell out here playing softball in
this league and what I'm trying to do it
put some positives back into him it's
still covered a little bit I grew up
with the negative that they not turn
positive nothing trying to be a better
example to him I look at three as a
brother we play Mondays Wednesdays
Fridays Saturday together and sometimes
Sundays
[Music]
when we do batting practice at 3 o'clock
in the morning you can call me at any
time no fan and I'm there for you you
always say that uh I got the talent and
you got a good future in front of you
but you're gonna have a lot of people
come at you where they trying to bring
you down and talk about you and you just
gotta leave that out the picture and
stay focused when I see something that
nothing I can help him with I don't
hesitate at all because his happiness is
more happiness than that trophy but next
week despite being on rival teams tree
and Tyrell have formed a family like
bond a league that started with four
teams has quickly doubled to eight and
it's helping people come together in
ways that was once I'd heard of
everybody needs a friend at the end of
the day and that's what I try to beat it
to real somebody that nothing he could
depend on where we come together it's
just a beautiful thing there's no drama
you don't see no police coming out
messing with us this is what I cell
therapy is we come out here and we just
want to show love
[Music]
[Applause]